[Applause]
the seventh pick was steph curry
layman shoots the three it's way off the
mark and jokic has it
so minnesota passed oh what a pass
thread to needle baby nicola joakids
read head to grabbing watch
watch this pass home bounce back and the
defense couldn't even react
i mean it gets right there underneath
not reed's legs
beauty
bob the foodie down on the baseline
filming that action
yeah so jamaica green no fouls to give
for the mavericks
denver's been in the bonus for a while
here in this fourth quarter
each team with one timeout left chance
at the last shot
jokic a chance to tie it oh jokic
hits and we are headed for
overtime as nicola yokic
buries a long two to tie it at the end
of regulation
just a simple play to get him in
isolation and
joking step back drains the shot
as the buzzer sounds and willie cauley
stein you have to give him space
because jokic is so good at drawing
fouls
with a nice little step back on the
baseline and he shot it over the
outstretched hands of
carly stein i'll tell you what there's
some
big-time plays here in this game ba and
i just loved how the offense just flowed
through him he didn't force a lot
as well offensively nice quick move on
oh my goodness
wow having a lot of encore time here
look at the quick
move here by the joker to go baseline
oh that's that's that's pretty special
right there the best thing
you know the start of yokitch's season
has been can't be
stars without space to do their thing
oh what a touch pass i mean
look at this touch pass that's seeing a
play
ahead of time and a beautiful finish by
millsap
boom out of bounds watches on lead
harris is out there
how about that you get a turnover right
here he can't wait to get him back
and he was talking about a perfect pass
i thought he was throwing to mills
well he overshot that touchdown sprint
get a couple of fast breaks see if
something picks up
there's that zone again volleyball's
it tanaji nice tip there oh nice
pass by the joke third or fourth
was his pass hold on i see capela come
up from playing low and just
volleyball is it boom
[Applause]
zeke magic saying hey i like playing
with this guy yeah it'd be a nice
one-handed set
in international 21 for zach levine
murray back to jokic and another dunk
that's 17 on the season and one
what do you mean the dunk contest get
out of the way
i'm going to set this screen jamal's
going to hit me on this roll and then
you know what i don't even care you can
send a body you can send the contact
doesn't matter i'm gonna finish right
through it and this is how i'm gonna
finish
can the nuggets get a stop porter junior
that's all fioke chase it
baseball pass porter's out there and he
puts it away
he leaked out of the shot challenged the
shot and went joker able to get it and
pull it long
the stifling they made an adjustment of
the defense event
great baseball pass perfect jackson is
there behind the back jokage thinking
three jokingly good feed
inside and he finds the cutting gordon
for two
what a pass by jokic look at this look
at all the black jerseys around jokic
little pump fake here draws a big crowd
and just
what a dime nuggets holding the 15 point
lead
jokic they double behind the back oh
there it was where's he see okay he saw
him right there he knows he's cutting
already
those are your favorite ones aren't they
i love it
one more look
[Music]
[Applause]
with another brilliant pack watch where
joker is going to pull up for the oh
here's that pass look he's looking one
way
he might have more free throws made than
you did that one year scott when you
shot
a hundred percent look at this
[Applause]
what two seconds larry walker hall of
famer said
nine kids you got time
that's a 90 foot pass on a dime look at
the clock nine tenths of a sec
catch dunk unbelievable
jokish against philly and bye
he puts billy in the rearview mirror
henry first
dumps it that's a fickle baldy right
there runs to the rim
not only the spin i said this the vic
lombardi because i
bledsoed ingram turns the corner pass it
underneath
blocked by jokic nicole yogas blocked
the ball
what's going to do is get it too he goes
right by porter
and somehow joker knocks it out of his
hands
wow and sometimes they talk
about lack of two million dollars
feeling very generous feeling daily
how about everybody now yokish sling
across
rivers for three and he gets set
and this pass that sling pass to the
corner austin rivers learning
knocked away for a moment jokic has it
baseball pass ahead
gordon with the easy two
yoke is spotting the open man
aaron gordon recognizing hey i'm just
gonna put my hands up i'm here
qb hit me going long i'll knock it down
now that gives your backside defense a
chance to get to the the cutter if there
is one but you just don't want dame
or cj or even normal powell for that
matter coming off screen shooting threes
[Music]
jokic spinning on nurkic and he beat him
entertaining first day of the nba first
round
some great games just saw the nets take
care of the celtics in comeback
fashion big shot by chris middleton for
the bucks earlier
with the big set when portland's biggs
set the screen for damian lillard he's
typically going to be open great pass by
but uh capazio but when damon lindler
comes off the screen he's waiting to see
how the big is going to play defensively
and can they create and i should say
continue to make enough shots from the
perimeter
to balance off what they're going to get
from the joker jokic
leads in as much as he can against
lillard
and and he did that's a good job
defensively even on a mate because
ultimately that's what you're looking
for is just to not give up
that the easy ones that are uncontested
in rhythm
seven seconds
lasers out of fouls joe kicks from three
get it dame littered back out there but
short
and mcconnum saves it but goes to porter
now capazo he's got the advantage and
capitalizes
and a timeout for terry stotts corner
pocket but he's not done
racking up assist on the top of assist
austin rivers number three
and he had big games early this season
for the knicks before he was waving what
footwork
the mvp he gets to the rack he's just
too small rookie from
argentina it's another half-court set
they got us this double has to come
quicker aaron gordon
saw it that's not a double like like
carmelo's walking over slowly
so it stays at three both teams
struggling right now and especially but
that's a beautiful bounce entry
it's compasso again on the dime i don't
like their start this game dibber has to
pick it up but that's a nice dime by
capazo
he's changed his game a lot improved his
three-point shot and has become one of
the better stretch fours we have in this
league as
the joker goes right down the lane
somebody has to slide over
now how about this i mean it looks like
it's going to be a dribble handoff he
fakes it but nerky
you may not ever see another game where
damian makes one field
that's amazing what a play by gordon
getting on the deck get it back to jokic
here he comes down the paint kick out
into the corner porter for three
got it able to get to the rack couldn't
finish here comes powell full head of
steam
joe gets clean block
[Applause]
lead that's a great play by gordon
attack that offensive glass get your
team another
opportunity here's joe
to skip porter for three got it
denver takes the lead michael porter jr
net nightmare game four
the 22 year old has responded tonight
basically
that's where he wants to be in clutch
situations making big time shots
if he keeps working like he's doing
right now ba
about your team you know what i mean not
bringing it there's a block by gordon
mccollum got his rebound but couldn't
finish it jokic kicks it
porter he's got the hot hand and he's
going to stay that way
what a start for michael porter junior
what's good about that look the
hesitation you attract the defense you
don't give it up
so portland doing a good job of their
live ball getting back now allowing
denver to
capitalize off of them my goodness
[Applause]
backing down kids a little help from
simon's there oh what a flurry of
[Applause]
reverse again the appreciation there's
monte morris
out of the pack with a rebound
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and a steal jokic he picks lillard
leaves it morris layup is good answering
the call right now for the nuggets and
the steal
active hands jokic once again puts it
[Applause]
against stuck shotgun down to four long
three is up and
good nicola jokic
gives the nuggets the lead here again is
crowder
and they go inside deflected ball good
defense by denver
here comes gordon a mid-season
acquisition and a fake and a drive and a
joker
[Applause]
here in the first game one the two in
the three seed jokic
right there they want to bring him out
now he chisels his way in and fades away
tough shot and he gets it to go denver
shooting 54 percent
with five three cupcake
feed booker can't get it defense there
by joker yeah it looks like
joker got a blocked shot on that got it
spins oh he glides for two and four of
the six games at the lakers coming off
that series
it's jokic beautiful feet great cut
they get the two gordon the vin seconds
[Applause]
what a great ricochet with your kitchen
swatting at the ball
drive there by payne 25-7 adam the floor
is yours good to see you
you too coach and uh sorry to interrupt
your meeting
as you said i have some important news
that is that it's my honor to announce
that
nicole yokic is this year's
most valuable player congratulations
this is the first mvp in nuggets history
right
and the first mvp second round
second round mvp first ever first in
franchise history
and first of many
[Applause]
i just want to tell you guys that this
is not my individual order of course
but i couldn't do it without you guys so
it's my own
it's my trophy whatever but you guys are
big part of it so thank you thank you
everybody
who is in this room thank you